our shout out tonight to an
investigative team at the Tampa Bay
Times that got a tip from a Children's
Hospital about a personnel change
crunched a huge download of medical data
and discovered children in a special
heart surgery unit were dying at a rate
that far exceeded any other Hospital in
the state the investigative report with
its own video was aptly named heart
broken at least 11 children dead in one
18 month period many others left
paralyzed or otherwise harmed surgeons
actually left a needle inside this
girl's heart and never told her parents
[Music]
you can be the best hands in Florida and
we find that there was in fact the
needle in her chest and after the
surgery was over when they did the count
they have to do to make sure they have
all the utensils and everything they
were missing a needle so they knew they
were missing the needle but they never
said anything to us it was that
troubling story that the reporters at
the Tampa Bay Times say made them
certain they were onto something big I'm
Kathleen McCrory I'm the deputy
investigations editor for the Tampa Bay
Times and I'm Neal Betty I am an
investigative reporter for the temp of a
times the reporters say the initial tip
came from someone who worked at the
Children's Hospital which had been taken
over by the prestigious Johns Hopkins
Medical Center its promotional videos
boast of a world-class reputation they
came in and told us that she had truncus
arteriosus they told us we'd be going to
Johns Hopkins all Children's
[Music]
they just kept telling us that there
wasn't a story here for a little while
and that they had self police themselves
out of their problems so there was no
point in us further investigating or
researching what was going on but
McQuarrie and Biddy ignored all that and
dug deeper into what happened at the
hospital's Heart Institute after Hopkins
had taken over after that happened there
started to be some serious clinical
issues in the program and that meant
that children were dying at a much
higher rate and there were far more
complications than this program was used
to it had tripled to about nine or ten
percent and that was the highest rate of
any program in Florida that we had seen
for the past decade and then using
social media as a starting point the
reporters began to hear from families
whose children had been at the Heart
Institute it was incredibly emotional I
mean the families were we're devastated
when they found out that what happened
to them didn't happen in isolation you
know that there were other families who
had experienced the same thing no family
more devastated than the Eskimo yes the
doctor came and
egos you know missing Escamilla you know
I just know something about I really
hate to tell you but your daughter just
suffered a stroke
[Music]
I used to remember looking at I just
burst out crying
the reporters uncovered one
heartbreaking case after another yeah in
many ways these were families who didn't
have a voice and in particular they
didn't have a voice alone you know but
when they came together they had much
more of a voice the full Tampa Bay Times
investigative report told a story that
some in the hospital had tried to keep
quiet you know it was only a few weeks
before they made pretty system-wide
changes to the hospital the CEO resigned
we saw three vice presidents resign two
surgeons left the hospital two heart
surgeons the chairman of surgery stepped
down from that post although he remains
at the hospital and the new hospital
president issued a remarkable apology to
the families and the employees who had
tried to blow the whistle I know
personally that many of you courageously
spoke out when you had concerns but were
ignored or turned away that behavior is
unacceptable and will not be tolerated
going forward and most importantly we
know an apology to the families and
patients who did not receive the
high-quality care that is our promise to
all patients I am deeply sorry for their
tragic losses it is devastating when a
child is harmed or life is lost for the
two reporters the profuse Hospital
apology served as a confirmation that
they were right to pursue the story in
the first place and they say there is
still more to do in a statement to us
that Johns Hopkins all Children's
Hospital said federal inspectors have
now removed the funding of patients
being in immediate jeopardy that all
deficiencies have been addressed so our
shout out tonight to Cathleen mcgrory
and Neil Divi and the editors at the
Tampa Bay Times for taking on one of the
country's most prestigious medical
institutions and producing the kind of
journalism that challenges the
established
and the powerful that's our program for
tonight thanks for joining us we'll see
you here next week